hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to soma now we're
approaching the whoa and apparently I'm
event a mistake that's gonna strike at
the heart of the whoa Wow
cuz reasons I don't know I'm just pretty
much doing on I'm told hey buddy I also
don't understand why you're here and
able to communicate with me the hell is
that it controls more structure gel and
pedals to poison the imprint and the
heart will unwillingly spread it across
to pusher oh that makes more sense
because after I got this new body when I
push my hand into the things but why
wait I'm just like hang on a sec here I
I want to know my options I want away
everything what's what's the reason for
it why am I do the thing what is the goo
be goo can I just go out would I want to
go out it seemed that the world easy
yeah I gotta think about this because I
mean admittedly it doesn't seem like the
WoW is doing very good but who am I to
say oh okay yeah hey don't tell me to
shut my arm in a figure out what to do
see I really got a I really got to think
the sound like what are the options I'm
just literally just being told what to
do
I mean this is literally a choice here I
could leave I could literally just leave
right now good night what would happen
what would happen if I just walked out
I'm intensely curious I'm not one to
follow the strict orders of people that
are shouting in my ear but I just kind
of want it what are my options but you
seem really sinister like no joke you
seem obscenely sinister why should I
listen to you I don't even know who you
are this is so weird
so bizarre
alright here's my reasoning behind I've
made my decision here's my reasoning
behind it I don't know who this guy is I
don't know why he's telling me to do
this I don't know what this has to do
with anything like this is totally off
the beaten path from what I was
originally here to do how do I know I
can try I'm not one to follow the
instructions of someone who's screaming
at me to do something so I've made my
own choices up to this point so here we
go I don't know if it's rad okay but
what about the arc I don't know what
wait how are you gonna make me wait is
my choice not even matter
hey now come on buddy why you gotta be
like that oh crap hello again I don't
you have to do this this is bigger than
both of us
well now I didn't even know what he was
you gobbled him right up whoa okay so
what the hell that's so cool
so what does that mean could I still ooh
no I don't want to do that no I don't
want to go through all that and then
just do it definitely not gonna do that
okay so that's the choice I made but
apparently that guy is now gone but see
like I don't I don't anticipate that the
WoW is intentionally evil because it
doesn't necessarily seem like that's
what it's all about now I may be totally
wrong
the old game
okay well I thought we were cool that's
how we're rose I thought we were on the
up-and-up
okay bye-bye
um
alrighty then dang
okay bon
what's what's what oh come on Zack I
can't get away head to mrs. Healy do
okay good to go to gumdrops oh come on
I think he's just being my friend and
just giving me a nice big hug thanks
douche I am like in pain I can't move
how is this fear you have bone to be
over oh come on with this ball I'm just
stuck in a loop of death there's no hope
for me there's no hope for any of us
Oh God yeah oh god no not again let me
shove my fist in one more hole this is
gonna play me up again then drop me
farther from my destination
this is oddly fair okay come on let's go
again
oh boy speedy speedy speedy speedy this
is not the correct way oh god I thought
I thought I was dead
okay I thought I was in this some weird
things going on here alright so not
again
now again I'm hippity hominin oh I'm
heaven I'm heaven and happening far as
fast as I can
I'm a hippity-hoppity all that stuff
again with this baloney
Here I am again on my own the only Road
I've ever known
seriously what is the deal what is going
on this is so weird
why is this happening can I make it kind
of make it this time am I gonna make it
probably not
Oh God whoa that was a little close
please boom boom oh god oh god oh no oh
no
okay come on get in there god damn it oh
man well there we are then
I still don't know if I made the right
choice it's so weird I really do wonder
like what what effect of these choices
gonna have I mean this seems like a big
one it seems like a really big one in
that I don't know my hair is like really
pink by the way
I keep looking at myself in the camera
I'm so beautiful I'm unbelievably
gorgeous I am incredibly incredibly
good-looking it's often a burden burden
being that's good
okay I haven't been able to talk to
Kathryn in a while
I just got an achievement called your
expressway to the stars that's what that
means fine right
hope the ark made it here in one piece
if it didn't and that's a whole lot of
[ __ ] that I got a deal with all
right what do we got here
no Healey whoo
oh here we go Catherine
can you hear me I hear you this is Phi
what happened to town a lot actually but
we're back on schedule now did you find
the ark I did but I kind of lost it on
my way here on an automated tram thing
headed to Phi so it should be around
somewhere that's great let's go get it
yay file looks relatively okay not as
infected his towel was I mean he's got a
problem thanks babe
my vision still a little blurred I could
use some Healy who I don't know where to
get it launch dome site map here we go
alright so I'm right there there's
something blinking in storage is that
where it put it that might be where it
put the thing the ark so a satellite is
loaded into a shell the shell is
accelerated by an electron rock that was
a penis that's data penis Oh in space
the satellite will shut the shop unfold
ah okay I gave us to settle the
satellite orbit okay alright that's all
then okay so cargo transport so it must
be in there so the ark is there requires
manual offload god dammit I can't doing
that staff activity not many people
doing a whole lot see unsigned our herb
herb er wait is that today uh oh Herbers
here herb herb buddy did you find out
what happened to the Arctic or am i her
not really I'm Herbert some reason they
didn't go through with the launch so
they took the ark back to tau I hope
everything's okay with this space gun
yeah I doubt I'll be able to repair one
of those
yeah I don't even know what I do for a
living well that looks interesting let
me see what the other door leads to
first I mean this obviously goes to the
launch dome so this is where I'd end up
but I'm pretty sure I don't need to be
here right now now I understand why the
space gun was at the bottom of the ocean
because oh I do not want to go that way
or just yet because that's the only way
I could have gained enough in the
longest day madam I
isn't it just been one day yeah
our time together is a confusing
patchwork of most any time is it doodle
what day it's May 11th 2004 3:30 a.m.
but I don't remember when we started me
neither
I actually have no idea huh
okay oh there's a he good just what I
needed
let me show me in you okay there we go
yeah so man you know I woke up in my bed
today it just happens to have happened a
hundred years ago
sounds like are you does I woke up in my
bed today a hundred years ago Who am I
Oh God deeply philosophical in the end
of that question well too bad suck it up
we got a job to do we gotta save the
humanities it's electrical hazard oh
well this would be it's crazy to think
where I am not only is this the future
it's in the middle of the sea I know
nothing of this time or what the world
looks like nice try but now before the
comet I guess it was okay yeah better
not oversell it might change my mind
about the arc
are you suggesting we keep it down here
doesn't that defeat the whole purpose
eternity among the stars remember the
people inside the Ark won't know the
difference we can just keep it down here
and we don't have to risk the ark being
shot through 5000 metres of broken
barrel and then push through another
hundred thousand metres of a dust filled
atmosphere will occasions stand all that
pressure well the odds aren't great
Katherine say something I don't care
what you think I'm launching it no need
to be like that let's just hang on to it
for a while and think about it we can
launch it later now that wasn't the deal
we needed to save them to launch it out
there it's hope down here it's a [ __ ]
terrarium waiting to die with the rest
of us come on Katherine it's not asking
much let's just think about it before we
risk the only hope humanity has to
survive this he'll know we launched it
today this is my project my Ark it's
bigger than that don't you get it it's
not for you to decide we're talking
about the fate of mankind get away from
the Ark
I'm taking it no you're not I'm not
gonna let you ruin this
it was an accident Katherine talk to me
Kathir what Katherine did you say
something
it's you you had an accident
what are you oh you mean Katherine don't
worry it's better this way
dang I think I found the assembly space
what do you see
it's like a huge open shell a bullet
ready to be loaded you escorted all
prepare for the arc right I'll go pick
it up well alright then I don't know
where I'm picking it up from but I'm
kind of a little lost on where I am
compared to where I need to be tomorrow
you got into a fight with your
colleagues they didn't want to risk
launching the arc thought it might not
make it through the atmosphere
hey terrible I'm sure it was an accident
they were just trying to stop you from
launching I'm sure it was an accident
oh is this where Katherine has a mental
breakdown I hope she can stand up - how
could they told Katherine I know I'm not
as a person to learn
don't do this to yourself
yeah I've been through more than you
have maybe out of this
we got the ark back hey job Simon take
it to the assembly space and load the
board you got it I'm with it can I take
this at the same time no I cannot I have
to come back for that Center also real
front yep
Lonzo some Jessi Sean Kevin Kevin I
always wanted a friend come real one
something you ever hold back way
I'll be your friend Oh pity friendship
now I feel even worse oh come on my
friendship don't mean that much to you I
thought we were buddies how the arc will
make it through the atmosphere and into
space
almost doesn't matter anymore we just
need to try we burn we burn if we're
lucky we just gave humanity a new chance
a whole new era maybe with the organist
maybe we have a few decades of power
dude you've been running in space we've
dozens of years still one hell of a
gamble though this was never about
certainty it's about hope all righty
then you say so here goes hope
bye-bye everybody
I'm really not that familiar with gums
of any size oh here we go
all systems say go lock and load
so I'm guessing we're not gonna be able
to get on the ark alrighty then
goody goody gumdrops we're here ready to
rock what will you do when you get into
the ark what's the first thing make sure
they are the same stabilize flight paths
activate solar panels
what's the first human thing you're
gonna do Oh which is a class Bob I know
what now we just need to get the show on
to the gun and then kaboom something how
are you gonna get us on board they are
don't we need to make another scan oh
don't you worry you don't operate
something like the Emmaus space gun with
your bare hands you mean it's a pilot
seat like back at Omicron yes and we can
use it to transfer you to the ark while
operating the gun to birds and all that
now take the aamna tool and plug it in
next to the seat and I'll guide you to
the final steps oh boy
we're gonna have another dilemma again
ah is this really gonna be the end of
the game I have no idea oh man I'm
getting anxious just thinking about how
this is gonna end
I dunno
I will give him credit they did build
the developers of this game built the
world that feels real that's the thing
about it definitely feels completely
real in the weirdest way
hello-oh nahama get stopped now who's
gonna do wrong where is it gonna go bad
boy I'll never get used to that guess
you won't have to not after this is over
right
have a seat Luke Edo Ewan I like how
everything's based on the brain scan
technology absolutely every tactical as
good as it's gonna get okay I like the
fantasy it should be able to use the
boys alrighty then how do you operate
this thing
don't know I never tried this one but
parties are notoriously easy to use so
it shouldn't be a problem
okay don't even oh hello oh okay
this is notoriously easy to handle oh I
got it
I've been doing a thing wowee Zowee I'm
gonna put it over there
where the green dot tells me to I need
to rotate this how do I rotate it
oh here we go get those artorias lazy to
use I wish everything in my life is as
notoriously easy
Fibby family okay ready when you are
just hit the button and we're off but we
need to transfer our minds to the ark we
also need to make sure launchers at all
so I tied them to a single switch just
push the button and we're off are you
messing with me are you a lying liar
you're lying to me aren't you nothing
Oh Oh do lates going now is this worthy
inevitable betrayal happens
time twenty seconds
what's the matter with the upload
don't you guys get a better bandwidth
oh no is it not gonna get to me
ten seconds
seven-six
fool
three
oh man still here
Catherine Catherine I'm here what the
hell happened what went wrong nothing
they're out there among the stars we're
here no we were getting on the ark I saw
it you'd finished loading just before it
launched yeah I saw then why are we
still here Simon I can't compel you how
works you listen you know I were here
you are copied onto the ark you just
didn't carry over you lost the coin toss
we both did
just like Simon it over on just like the
man who died in Toronto 100 years ago
this is [ __ ] we came all this way we
launched the ark I know it sucks but our
copies are up there Kathryn and Simon
are both safe on the ark be happy for
them are you crazy
we're gonna die down here with those
[ __ ] living large on a spaceship
they're not us they're not us I'm sorry
you feel that way Simon I'm proud of
what we did make sure that something of
the hundreds of thousands of years of
human history survived that's something
the song oh [ __ ] this [ __ ] [ __ ] this
[ __ ] you [ __ ] you Kathryn you lied and I
believed in you and I trusted you you
said we're getting all the [ __ ] art
we are you idiot I didn't lie I can't be
ignorant
Catherine please don't leave me alone
Catherine Catherine oh that's all I had
a feeling I had a feeling jagged rock Oh
silver [ __ ] okay
well very happy then oh I'm not
disappointed in the anagen I've just
blows Louisa that's gonna be a thing
Josh okay all right so that's what I
expected was gonna happen I had an
inkling I just didn't want to say
anything yet because I had a pretty good
idea that because it had copied you know
it shifted the perspective of the game
to me as opposed to or to the new suit
as opposed to that I had a feeling that
it would continue the story of the game
from the perspective of me that it was
left behind therefore it really hammers
home in case people didn't understand
the concept that you know it's not
actually a coin toss it literally just
to different people at that point but
there it is you know don't even get to
see the inside of the Ark all that like
the whole thing of the game and I was
certain to this while I was getting
anxious up to the point because I I feel
like some people wouldn't understand
the futility of it is actually the story
like late like some people might say
that this game ends with like it didn't
matter what I did but it didn't matter
what you did you just didn't feel the
end result of what it mattered and
that's the point it's trying to make
like like I love this game
I'm gonna say it right now I love it
it's amazing this was awesome I loved
everything about it
game was kept me engrossed the
philosophy of it the scares of it like
is it was such a cool game such a
well-made game such a well-made idea and
yet I fear that it will go over a lot of
people's heads if they don't really wrap
their head around the subject of the
fact that like does it not not the fact
the question of does it matter you know
if something's just a copy or if it's
really alive because if something goes
on to commit the continued the purpose
that it's set out to do but it's a copy
of what originally set out to do it does
that really matter is what like what's
the difference so ah man there was such
a cool gaming and just like there's so
few stories that don't let it's like a
it's almost a bittersweet ending but not
really because the point it's trying to
make is that it was it from the
perspective of those that were left
behind it's not satisfying but for those
that were copied it is it's a story that
could only exist in this universe that
they created for this expects purpose to
ask this question and that is so cool I
don't know if anything I said just made
sense but it's so cool everything about
this was so cool hey
well is this
did it work
okay all right
welcome if you're reading this you have
successfully entered the ark the survey
is designed to give the developers a
better understanding of your subjective
experience and how to improve your
well-being please continue with the
survey how do you describe your physical
condition I feel I feel normal
apparently how would you describe your
mental condition I feel normal
apparently it's like pre-selected for me
see how would you describe your senses
see as expected normal how would you
describe the sensation of your new
condition its pleasant compared to what
was just before are you troubled by the
fact that you're no longer strictly
human no I feel fine
see how do you perceive your new
existence it's a direct continuation of
my previous life do you think this new
existence will be a life worth living
yes just as much as my previous life
would you rather be removed from the
project and accept death no your answers
have been saved thank you for
participating oh that's so cool I was
about to go into big speech about how it
was okay that it ended the way it did
end it's only fine it didn't have to
come this like it's totally like not not
a big deal that it does this but I mean
it would have been totally fine if it
didn't either because the story in
itself and the ideas that it grows and
the ideas that it puts forward in the
way it shows it to the user like us the
player of the game is really really
interesting
hello cirthree hey how's it going give
me a hug it actually made it well we did
I'm so relieved
okay Simon everything's all right now
oh my god
Oh
oh man oh man
I am I am blown away by this and I mean
I said in the beginning when I started
playing this that the idea of the last
vestige of humanity floating through
space just a lonely speck was sad and I
would still say it's true because like
looking down I was wondering if it was
gonna look at the earth and it was gonna
be totally fine and they just thought
that a meteor happened but you know I'm
glad they committed fully and there
actually was a meteor Athena it came
together what that's so cool
ah that's so cool everything about this
was so cool I love this game to death
this is ah such a cool game I love this
game to death I mean I've been trying to
wrap my brain around how I'm gonna say
my thoughts is it drifting apart you'd
ripped it apart there without what
you're doing either way so I just want
to say this game was awesome the
experience that it gave was really
really something special I wouldn't say
it was like the scariest game I've ever
played I mean it definitely had a lot of
heart pounding like tense moments but
you know as far as like pure scare you
know it wasn't as scary as like some
games I've played in the past but still
a lot of scares it had an incredibly
complex and interesting story like
intriguing - like as all hell is the
only way I could describe it it's just
so cool and I bet there's so many
mysteries and little pieces of story
that were like scattered about
throughout the game but you know in the
end it's actually interesting because
the choices that I make don't really
affect the outcome unless you think of
the world as a continuation of what
happens after the game because people
often say that when a movie ends the
characters lives still continue on and
the lives of this still carry on is to
set from my perspective you know they're
not my concern anymore but they still
exist you know what I mean so that's the
interesting thing about it like the
people on the ark they continue their
existence whatever that may be
Digital real it continues and then on
earth because I didn't kill my old self
it's still on Omicron and it'll wake up
and it'll be very upset
and then like but in all reality Simon
died a hundred years ago what does it
all mean so complex and so interesting
like the answers are really there for
you to interpret for yourself so they
are what they are as you make them sorry
I can't stop playing with my bright pink
hair so either way thank you everybody
so much for watching I really hope you
enjoyed the series I had a ton of fun
playing it I almost couldn't put it down
it is an amazing game and if you want to
play for yourself I highly recommend
getting this game it's not a sexy dog
game I think it's still 30 bucks or
maybe it's on sale either way this game
is awesome thank you everybody so much
for watching support the developers
frictional games did an amazing job with
this I love it to death and as always I
will see you in the next video bye bye